les vacances un droit pour tous et tout
au long de l'année c'est le credo du
secours populaire aux clayes-sous-bois
fatoumata sept ans s'apprête à partir
pour la première fois aux sports d'hiver
alors au moment de faire la valise le
choix est difficile
un cul occasion par par exemple dans la
neige et ça s'il fait un peu beau je
suis plus content autres mais sauf que
j'avais que ça se passe bien on voit et
pato blessures
et devenir sos car c'est un truc
la petite fille est déjà parti en
vacances cet été avec le secours
populaire
le billet de train est à la charge de
l'association et le reste du séjour à la
famille d'accueil pour sarhane sa maman
ses vacances loin des clayes-sous-bois
permettent un moment d'évasion mais
aussi de la responsabiliser quand elles
viennent
elle s'appelle lui s'est elle fait elle
fait tout tout seul avant ça elle peut
pas fait sans moi être pas d'homme ça -
vraiment très près comptable l'opération
copains des vacances donne surtout la
chance aux enfants des familles
défavorisées de se faire de nouveaux
amis
les bénévoles dont qui sont les premiers
à voir les enfants et elle elle est
ramenée au treasure retour donc je me
disent qu'à chaque fois les enfants sont
ravis qu'ils ont pu faire des activités
qui ne pouvaient pas forcément faire
chez eux à la maison on a également des
enfants qui ne veulent pas repartir qui
fait rester dans la famille d'accueil
8h27 direction de tarbes ce lundi matin
pour fatou matin à la gare montparnasse
la séparation avec sa maman est
difficile mais dans dix jours elle
reviendra avec des souvenirs plein la
tête rattrapent les copies que c'était
bien les vacances
et je me suis bien amusé
l'été dernier car mon enfant yvelinois
ont pu profiter de l'opération copains
des vacances du secours populaire